good morning good morning garden Wow
Sunday you look incredible
thank you sir I feel bad I do I feel
never read it to be honest with you
great Oh with the fresh shave new
haircut
I feel amazing I feel like a million
dollars feel like what I spend on my end
what do you guys think of your new
innkeeper innkeeper and an owner right
when I first arrived I drove into the
Four Seasons Inn but this establishment
it's a one-off it's not part of a chain
right so you deserve your name your own
identity and something that you can be
proud of everybody is gonna know you now
as Layla's Riverside Lodge is amazing
the names awesome the sun's beautiful
it's just uh screams and me what do you
think I think it's absolutely perfect
and represent something so meaningful to
Sandy yep see right you okay you sure
I'm positive
yeah what do you think we go sighs love
to this is the new reception area have a
look at this
[Music]
Wow so let's welcome our guests in to a
proper reception area
this is inviting this is wall I love it
breathtaking is it lovely gorgeous
welcome to the thing that makes your
Lodge unique a new and improved dog
kennel amazing I'm stunned we doubled
the size of these kennels we've made
them feel luxurious
we have beautiful brand new bedding when
I first arrived these kennels felt like
a prison now it feels like a reward or a
treat any dog lover want their dogs to
stay even now this part for me is one of
most exciting parts come this way please
commit
I've never seen the kennel with that
many dogs and that many people that many
smiles the dogs are here because we've
organized their dogs ility competition
Oh No kidding
Wow all the owners will be checking and
staying in the in perceiving this kind
of event can be done every month which
will drive dog refused us to come and
stay in your stunning Lodge good morning
how you feeling today the sun is shining
and it seems to be a new right breath of
fresh air on the towns in we're missing
somebody here yeah she's been busy over
the last 24 hours
I'm hoping you notice a change I don't
even dress like this to go to church
right now somebody's looking like an
owner of it in yeah you look amazing
hey summer with an Amish Mennonite
lifestyle yeah I live radically
different look amazing looks are
different I can look good really good
are you ready to go inside I've been
dreaming of this moment follow me let's
go come on all of you
[Music]
[Applause]
what's missing in should look like a
tiny little convenience store that is
bright and modern and everything is on
view and even if you're not staying in
the end guess will come in and buy stuff
you can sell stuff properties that's
proper little boutique it looks amazing
amazing what Gordon is done is
phenomenal the store here looks great
it's like walking into a whole nother
place please God is the dust well done
beautiful design beautiful but I wanted
this dining room first off it was dreary
and ladened with junk and now we have a
proper dining room yes Oh lovely
all day menu the menu hangs on the wall
is written daily according to what
you've got available Jeff yes we run out
we tear it off and we start again you
turn around you'll see the custom
artwork on the wall please do not paint
over that there's one more little
feeling to show you in this place
beautiful then gorgeous pool they're
both you come in for two seconds
[Music]
now living in that tiny room with no
windows is not way to live so this is
your new apartment I rented this for the
next six months I'm sure when the
business kicks off you'll have
sufficient funds to render Sparling oh I
love it open plan kitchen lounge how
quick look at the bedrooms through there
beautiful this is just what we really
need it for Dave and me to get away some
time out there's yours
thank you thank you again that's awesome
I'm just damn flabbergasted actually
being on sites and not having time house
of your hotel you were blind to the
potential on your doorstep was
ridiculous we thought Gordon was just
coming here to help us with the business
he ended up being helping us emotionally
our marriage he very much wanted for us
to be together
and that was so lovely I've heard em all
so no question about it
really really nice yes thank you again
now I'm gonna hurt you okay I'm gonna
spend some quality time together now you
deserve good night and good luck
all right bye Gordon